do you know how many single employee
multi-millionaires are gonna get created
in the next 20 years it is going to be
insane I mean we know several of them
already but yeah a ton I agree with that
you're gonna sit in front of your little
portal into the [__] internet and I
look at like the line of progress it is
not linear it is exponential in terms of
how many people are figuring this out
everyone's like I want to go build the
next you know super sexy app or whatever
sure maybe you can do that but guess
what is actually going to be more likely
so you're going to figure out some way
to take your uh Consulting skills you're
going to put up a landing page right
people are going to hit you up and
you're going to charge them a reasonable
rate and you're going to do it from
anywhere in the world behind your
computer and you're going to make 350
000 you're gonna do that for a decade
and you're literally gonna go flex at
your kid's school and be like I'm rich
yeah right and you guys are all going to
an office